وبضربه محولات الطاقه الاوكرانيه
بعد ما تجرعته الصناعتها منذ بدايه الحرب
وليس بسبب الندره وانما بسبب العقوبات
الغربيه مؤثره نعم ولذلك تطالب كيف الان
بزياداتها في ما يخص انتاج الصواريخ
عديده دمرت العسكريه تحديدا واكثر
القطاعات التضررا الدبابات الروسيه سلاح
رئيسا في العقيده العسكريه نسخه تي 90
مثلا لا يمكنها القتال ليلا بكفاءه دون
نظام كافرا للتصويب الليلي للدبابات وهذا
يسمح للدبابات بتدقيق التصويب لمسافه 10
كيلو مترات ليلا وحتى وراء غطاء غابات
كثير
شركه روسيه بدعم تقنيه وقطع غيار من شركه
تليس الفرنسيه وقبل الحرب كانت روسيا تجهز
لمئتين 250 دبابه تي 9 بالنظام المتطور
لكن وبسبب العقوبات الان تعويضها باتا شبه
مستحيل كيف يؤثر ذلك على روسيا بحلول
الشتاء المعروف بلياليه الطويله في
اوكرانيا الدبابات تفقد القدره على
المناورات الليليه موسكو مضطره لتعويض
نظام كافر في معدات روسيه قديمه في 90
ستصبح مجرد مدرعه صوفيا التقليديه وامام
الوضعيه الصعبه موسكو تحركت للالتفافيه
على العقوبات تاره عبر تاسيس شركه في
هولندا لشراء ارادرات ومعالجه المتطوره
قبل ارسالها عبر بلدا ثالث وطاره عبر
الحلفاء الهند مثلا طلبت منها قائمه بال
في منتجه
يحتمل الاستخدام المزدواج المدني وعسكري
اما تركيا فتحولت اكبر من وجهه للمنتجات
المحربه وحداتها من امريكي لكن لماذا
انقره هي عضو الاتحاد الجمركي الاوروبي
امر يسهل عليها وصول السلع الغربيه بجانبي
عدم التزامها بالعقوبه الغربيه
[موسيقى]